[Music]
I'm reto Meier and I'm Stephanie Wong
here with AMA it's a very VP of
engineering to dive into api's welcome
and thanks for joining us thanks for
having me so I want to talk about AP is
which have come a long way from the
software interfaces popularized by 132
ap is tell us where they are today and
your predictions for AP is in 2019 and
where ap Apogee lies in this space
sure sure I think if you look at what's
going on in the industry today there
many things which are driving the
modernization of a lot of the existing
applications right so if the eyes are
becoming the front end to a lot of the
assets companies have already in their
portfolio and the unlock a lot of those
content for different kind of users be
it end-users be partners as well as
employees so I think if you look at
going forward in 2019 you start seeing a
lot of different ways of exposing those
api's one the lot of companies are using
trying to monetize on them to be able to
kind of use that to create a lot of new
content as well as partnerships so we a
lot of good examples of customers like
say magazine Luiza in Brazil who is
trying to create a lot of e-commerce
kind of content and be able to expose a
lot of data to the end-user to buy it
same thing with AccuWeather where they
want to be able to now take a lot of the
weather data and share it and bring it
make it available to a lot of other end
users as well so that's one kind of
driving factor second thing is
popularization of a lot of ways of
interfacing through voice and text so
you can see BOTS you see of course a
different kind of consumer devices and
that requires a lot of interfaces into
the backend systems and be able to
expose it through Y syntax so that's
also driving a lot of interest from
companies to be able to use API
management for that and third area we
seen a lot of kind of driving factor and
you see a lot of it as we move forward
it's a lot of Industry requirements all
right so there's a lot of open standards
coming out a lot of regulations coming
out and api's is the one way to kind of
lock the content and make sure they're
secured and they are available to the
right people so that's another complete
new requirement to be seeing and
becoming very popular as we move forward
that's exciting
now obviously a lot of API is that drive
ecosystems are publicly visible
but many of the IP is at any given
company are only used internally how
does Apache support both of those use
cases sure so I think the way we have
build a platform at in the Apogee area
was to really make sure that anybody who
wants to expose the api's we provide
them ways to kind of manage the whole
process beat internal external users and
so the platform is really kind of
agnostic of that fact but the of course
prove provide a lot of safeguarding when
it's externally exposed a lot of the
right kind of regulations the right kind
of permissions security elements are
built in
similarly inside when you try to expose
it inside their enterprise and way they
use it between different employees for
different application development again
we provide the whole lifecycle
management for it so there are a lot of
again capabilities for a developer to
use and leverage when they're building
those applications and they can decide
the rules and how and what the to be
shared and a lot of features kind of
build in to really make that happen and
a lot of companies are now looking
towards micro services but micro
services will continue have a lot of
different recipes successful micro
service architecture is complex to
design build and manage and there are a
lot of experimentation going on but the
key is to build reusable decoupled
services I could scale with the right
levels of governance how is a pudgy
helping to support micro service
architecture I think general if you look
at the architecture evolution in general
is ideas we really have a small small
kind of services and kind of decoupled
in a way right and then the best way to
kind of use those services is through an
API so what what Apogee does is now that
we have interface is to kind of a lot of
the micro services management layer and
for example sto which Google provides as
a service allows you to now expose those
micro services manage them in a much
better way and orchestrate and kind of
we do a lot of monitoring around it and
what we do with Apogee is we integrate
with steel and really provide the
ability to manage those API is through
one of those channel one one way
otherwise if you have other micro
services you have an API we can of
course manage that lifecycle for that
and allow you to use as micro services
in a much better fashion than a monetary
complication would be yes can you talk a
little bit about the new general
availability release of effigy edge for
a private cloud yeah I think the way the
baby looking at Apogee in general is to
have a deployment model which is
flexible right so one is to be able to
have core
you can continue using it on tram second
thing is to be able to now take it in
the cloud we have an Apogee edge
products available in the cloud as well
fully managed by Google third is this
hybrid mechanism where you can have some
of the runtime running anywhere you
choose be the private cloud or
on-premise you can be running on
kubernetes or gke and they'll run and
the control plane is running in the
cloud and could that could be in any any
cloud could be a Google or any third
party cloud as well so we try to make
sure their architecture is very flexible
giving choices to the customers and
developers to really deploy the way they
would want to and specifically with edge
we do provide a private cloud edition
where you can run on GK and GK
on-premise can be available anywhere
developer want to choose to deploy it
and we allow you to kind of have it very
easy and easy to manage and easy to
deploy so that's available today and we
continue to kind of make progress in
that area setting so we know that API is
and building api's isn't just enough you
have to actually convince your
developers to do them and that means
developer portals become key how does a
pichu's developer portal and it's
enhancements help that happen yeah I
think to tie everything together you
have to have them have a structure where
this information can be available right
so the developers of course would love
to have one way of in terms of how you
manage those atrs but how do you expose
it is through a developer portal so
Apogee provides a lot of capabilities on
the developer portal site so we have a
customer facing portal a partner facing
portal all the lifecycle for kind of
getting API into the portal as well all
the services are available so developer
doesn't have to do a lot of the heavy
lifting in terms of how to share that
content how to use kind of get right
kind of security around it so the
developer portal today is available
through all of our other products and we
keep on making enhancements to it
there's one offering through Drupal as
well to a third-party CMS if a customer
chooses to use a heavy duty
portal and has a lot more capabilities
for a lot of specific things custom work
you might want to do but we also have an
integrated portal is part of our
offering today which is very simple easy
to use and you can create a lot of
interface into portal interfaces for
end-users very quickly and easily that's
great Epogen some best practice to help
create world-class developer experiences
right so tell me a little bit about
more about that I think in general I
think just not Apogee if you look at
Google we've been trying to make sure
the Google cloud mega developer
experience very friendly right and I
think one of the key things for
developer is the lifecycle of how do you
create an application and deliver that
at the one big part of that is the API
management for it in terms of the whole
lifecycle so we have made sure if a
developer it's very easy to onboard they
can start writing an API they can start
kind of documenting it testing it and
and design and delivering it so we
provide a lot of tooling for that very
simple easy to use and what we've been
doing beyond that it's really how now
kind of giving you metering monitoring
monetization so now we have an idea
who's using what what kind of security
you have what kind of privileges were
provided to that user as well as what
kind of uses you got out of it and how
much money you can make out of it so you
have a lot of that data available to the
area fingertips so we've been doing a
lot of work to really add a lot of this
value add the unjust been able to build
an API and deliver it but also all the
things you needed on monitoring metering
security monetization so that's really
becoming very powerful element into the
feature capabilities for developers and
anybody also wouldn't do this work thank
you so much omote we packed a lot of
info into our talk so thanks for your
time thanks for having me
[Music]